[Musique]
je considère que nous ne n'y a pas de
droit à l'enfant le grand absent de ces
auditions préparatoire au débat que nous
avons vu çà a été l'enfant on n'a pas
parlé des droits de l'enfant galap et
manager player pour moi vont ensemble je
suis très hostile à gpa vraiment je
crois que c'est la marchandisation du
corps sait et on aura des dérives tu es
donc je vais évidemment je m'oppose à la
pma parce que c'est une étape
intermédiaire écoutez ce qu'a dit le
premier ministre quand il n'était pas
encore premier ministre il a dit on ne
fera pas la pma parce que la pma
entraînera la gpa premiers ministres
edouard philippe ci devient que la
garantie d'un garnement
et maintenant on nous explique ne vous
inquiétez pas on fera la pma mais il y
aura pas la gpa plus trouve assez
indécent qu'on met en concurrence à la
fois sur les files d'attentes pour
accéder aux produits minces à dire aux
gars mettent des personnes qui souffrent
de pathologies et des personnes qui ne
sont pas malades et pourquoi la société
prendrait en charge des actes pour des
personnes l'objectif de tariq ramadan et
de souffler sur les braises de faire de
ce procès n'ont pas le procès de tariq
ramadan
accusé de viol par six femmes mais
finalement celui de deux d'une
communauté religieuse qui seraient
discriminés et qui à travers lui dont il
serait le leader est le symbole serait
traîné dans la boue cet homme est un
manipulateur
il a prétendu défendre un islam intégré
en fait et y défendre l'islam intégriste
il appelle ses 30% de radicaliser à se
lever contre la société française il
rêve d'une france qui révèrent une forme
de guerre civile et il veut que ces gens
qui sont en scission en rejet de la
france se lève pour faire ce procès non
pas celui de tariq ramadan mais celui
d'une communauté musulmane d'une partie
de la communauté musulmane radicaliser
contre la justice française c'est
extrêmement dangereux
au final ce sont les islamistes avec les
dealers de drogue qui tiennent ces
quartiers qui sont de plus en plus
important c'est plus des quartiers
parfois c'est des villes entières et et
vous avez une france parallèle où il n'y
a plus d'idées de république où c'est
souvent la charia qui domine et la
violence et il va falloir faire un vrai
travail pour reconquérir cela mais ça
passe aussi d'abord en amont par une
limitation de l'immigration je pense
qu'il faut arrêter l'immigration de
masse et je pense qu'il faut que la
france reprenne le contrôle de son
destin
[Musique]